dozens dead and dozens injured after a
fire caused a stampede among worshipers
at a coptic christian church in the
egyptian city of giza
the incident happened as thousands
gathered for morning mass at the abu
safin church
i saw people jumping from the upper
floor suffocation suffocation all of
them did so many dead and there are
children we didn't know how to get to
them we didn't know whose son this is or
whose daughter that is how is this
possible
giza sits at the southern edge of the
greater cairo area one of the most
densely populated places in the world
dilapidated infrastructure means
accidental fires are common
made more likely due to the record high
temperatures across the region
the fire in abu safin church thought to
have been caused by a faulty air
conditioner
we started to see from the outside that
the smoke was getting bigger and people
were wanting to jump from the upper
floor of the building of the church to
the next and one did then we went inside
and found the children and we started to
take the bodies out
in the aftermath of the incident
president abdel fattah al-sisi announced
the mobilization of quote all state
services to ensure that all measures are
taken the prosecutor's office has also
opened an investigation
some of the injured were firefighters
the blaze blocked an exit trapping
churchgoers and causing the stampede
according to eyewitnesses most of those
killed were children
zane basravi al-jazeera
let's bring in adam
for an update he's a journalist based in
cairo welcome to al jazeera so the
official death toll right now stands at
41 can we expect it to be much higher
it is expected to start to be a little
bit higher not much as far as the
official figures from the government is
concerned the health ministry confirmed
that as you've said 41 have been
died in the fire and 14
are injured this is the number that the
health ministry has registered and is
giving health care services too among
these 14 for are in critical conditions
they are in intensive care units where
health officials are treating them and
trying to make their health condition
steady as much as possible from the 10
remaining two have been
given the green light to go home they've
been dismissed from the hospital and
they are in good condition to go home
the rest are being treated but according
to the health ministry most of their
injuries
injuries are not so concerning so it
might
increase a little bit due to the four
and the uh remaining critical condition
and remain to be in the icu units
tell us a little bit more about the
church itself and the area that the
church is located in because presumably
it would be a highly congested area in
in giza
definitely it is a district called
imbaba one of the most
populous and dense population dense
districts in
greater cairo it is known to have a
general average socioeconomic background
this is a sunday service and of course
it means that the church is usually at
its full capacity it's at his busiest um
prayer service all over the week and
therefore the numbers of people there is
quite um significant it is the biggest
number ever all over the week uh finally
the church itself because of the
district um and its dynasty the church
is not a common structure church it's
not a big facility with a huge area of
land and many
entries and exit points it's more or
less like a
residential building um in terms of its
design and therefore the exits and
entries to that building are not so many
and because according to the health
ministry the fire that was sparked by
one of the ac
air conditioning devices in the second
floor um there was huge smoke and most
people could not get out and many of
them died because of suffocation from
the smoke rather rather from the flames
itself this is what we know so far in
terms of the incidents and how it
unfolded
i mean this is not the first tragedy in
egypt where fires have been to
been to blame really in recent years and
that's because of uh poorly enforced
safety standards in egypt how how common
are these types of accidents or
incidents
so if we're talking about fire incidents
in churches or in prayer houses it's not
common um i mean in recent memory i
can't really recall when was the last
time
that happened and even in public
transportation there was one incident
many years ago
was quite um a remarkable uh figure in
terms of casualties but also since then
um nothing major has been reported at
least we're not we're talking about fire
incidents you're not transportation and
accidents for instance and therefore um
there is a lot of work to be done in
terms of the infrastructure and imposing
and safety measures it is being
implemented in all the new cities and in
all
the
urban expansion that the egyptian
government is leading where silicon
people are and
buildings are still under construction
therefore there is room for the
government to
apply new regulations and for developers
to match and meet these regulations but
of course for the decades old uh
infrastructure uh of egypt and greater
carrier specifically it becomes more
challenging to implement the government
regulations in terms of um safety and
specifically uh fire and safety and
security okay thank you so much adam for
giving us that update from cairo